bonjour pierre alexandre la faille de la
société financière green seal a fait peu
de bruit dans les médias mais pourrait
bien avoir d'importantes répercussions
sur l'économie expliquez-nous
pierre-alexandre vous qui avez écrit à
ce sujet est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus alors effectivement guijin a
un nom connu du grand public qu'il
s'agisse d'une société internationale
qui revendiquait 143 milliards de
dollars de prêts à court terme aux
entreprises dans 175 pays dont la france
le dépôt de bilan de green day qui a eu
lieu le 8 mars dernier au royaume uni
les ondes dans une grande incertitude
ses clients qu'ils faisaient appel à ses
services pour payer leurs factures en
cas par exemple de manque de trésorerie
ce qui est souvent le cas depuis le
début de la crise que nous traversons
vous venez de le dire certains clients
de gris niveau d'activité en france
qu'elles pourraient donc être les
répercussions de cette faillite sur
notre économie est bien green qu'il
comptait parmi ses gros clients gfg
alliance un groupe industriel adorent et
annick qui possède entre autres la cire
gascoval à saint saulve et dunkerque
aluminium dans le nord une usine de raï
liberty style à hayange en moselle ainsi
que les fonderies dans le poitou et si
le français pourrait se trouver en
grandes difficultés notamment à cause
d'un prêt de 50 millions d'euros que les
îles de l'est font des races covan et
aline d'allanche way une situation qui
inquiète particulièrement les élus
locaux
oui en effet même si bruno le maire a
affirmé que l'état sera derrière les
salariés
le maire et rennes dayan chf fabien
engelmann inde et à devenir lui-même
actionnaire de cette usine de rats qui
compte 400 employés tandis que les élus
de gauche de la région tels qu aurélie
filippetti compter les pouvoirs publics
à reprendre le site avec un investisseur
privé ainsi que le président ait l'air
du grand test jean rottner considère
comme un enjeu de souveraineté nationale
voilà on assiste donc à une sorte
d'union sacrée transpartisane pour
lutter contre la réaction en chaîne née
de la faillite te critique merci
beaucoup pierre alexandre faire les
tickets on retrouve vos articles sur
notre site
rt france pointe m